vous dites pour la première fois de sa
vie en fait il pouvait être sincère
on sentait qu'il y avait il y avait plus
de barrières
notre invité du samedi 20h ce soir Kamel
gueloul bonsoir
alors Kamel ancien toxicoman à la tête
d'une association de prévention contre
la drogue vous avez été compagnon de
route de Jean-Luc Delarue lors de sa
tournée en camping-car à la rencontre
des collégiens et lycéens de France
voilà au cours de cette rédemption vous
êtes devenu amis c'est beaucoup confié à
vous vous nous raconterez tout ça à 20h
Kamel rebonsoir vous êtes né le 26 mai
1972 à Blois dans le Loir-et-Cher permet
canicien automobile mère femme au foyer
en France plutôt joyeuse un peu
turbulente un petit peu qui prend fin à
l'âge de 12 ans lorsque votre père se
tue dans un terrible accident de voiture
et vous dites c'est à partir de là que
tout est parti en vrille
ouais c'est là que ben j'ai perdu les
repères enfin voilà c'est le cas de le
dire alors après le décès de votre père
un jour sans savoir pourquoi vous
décidez de sécher les cours vous rentrez
chez vous et là vous découvrez les
portes et les volets fermés vous frappez
vous cogner rien ne se passe vous brisez
un carreau vous rentrez chez vous et
vous trouvez votre mère étendue sur le
lit
tentative de suicide suite à la mort de
mon père
alors à l'époque que j'ai un peu
d'élevage donc elle avait pris des
médicaments pour chien
et elle sera envoyée quelque temps en
hôpital psychiatrique dans la commence
votre descente aux enfers la spirale
auto-destructrice vous commencez par
bouffer les cachets qu'on donne à votre
mère mais vous ajoutez rapidement du
whisky très vite
et pour payer tout ça vous mettez à
faire des petits Lars quoi à voler oui
ensuite vous passez au haschich
25 g par semaine à 14 ans
beaucoup quand même
j'étais plutôt dans l'excès ouais j'ai
toujours été dans l'excès
et ensuite c'est les roues c'est un mec
qui vous en propose en vous disant c'est
pas de l'Hérault super copain
on appelle ça de la marron et vous vous
en prenez et vous dites je suis tombé
dedans en 4 jours quoi dans 4 jours
j'ai ouvert les yeux quelques années
après
alors comme l'héroïne vous endort vous
la mélangez à de la cocaïne et vous
faites ce qu'on appelle un Speedball
quoi
un moment vous êtes quand même à 3 g
d'Éros en grammes de coco par jour
si vous coûte quand même 3000 euros par
mois minimum
à Quiberon
le premier pas trop des héros pour
pouvoir être gigolo parce qu'il faut
quand même assuré
en prison et vous dites là ça a été le
paradis de la cam quoi parce qu'en fait
ce qu'on apprend quand on s'intéresse à
votre histoire c'est que dès le premier
soir vous recevez une petite feuille de
papier avec une ligne une ligne des rots
dessus quoi direct bienvenue alors vous
êtes dites j'ai pas été une seule fois
en manque c'est clair alors la
rédemption viendra de votre fille
un jour elle vous dit papa aujourd'hui
tu t'es enfermé neuf fois dans la salle
de bain c'est vrai que tu te drogues
et là ça a été le choc
moi qui pensais que je gérais que
personne voyait
généralement un petit univers et en fait
ma fille se rendait compte
et là vous dites il faut que je m'arrête
quoi
heureusement que vous avez une fille ben
ça a été voilà
m'a sauvé vous décrochez physiquement
assez rapidement
mais psychologiquement ça vous prendra
une dizaine d'années quoi
vous y pensez plus là non ça va c'est
réglé parallèlement vous vous lancez
dans le travail associatif
c'est vrai qu'on est des drogués mais on
ne faisait pas de prévention sur les
jeunes on leur expliquant ce que c'était
et donc pour la première fois un ancien
tocs va parler au tox et ça marche
il raconte leur histoire
on l'a tous une raison moi je connais
pas toxicoman heureux les gens qui
soient dépendants et heureux moi j'en
connais pas et voilà comment s'en sortir
c'est vrai qu'au début on en prend pour
pour être bien puis rapidement on en
prend juste pour pas être mal quoi
exactement alors voilà vous décidez de
monter votre propre association pour
faire de la prévention auprès des jeunes
vous dites on est dans les soirées
techno on tombait sur des mômes qui
savaient même pas ce qu'ils avaient pris
pour moi l'ignorance augmente la
vulnérabilité c'est vrai que tant qu'on
n'est pas informé on est vulnérable et
ça les dealers ils savent bien c'est
important d'avoir un discours pour en
parler déjà
alors vous commencez à faire des
tournées dans les collèges dans les dans
les lycées et c'est comme ça que vous
rencontrez Jean-Luc Delarue donc
lui-même sur le chemin de sa propre
rédemption c'est directeur de l'école
qui m'appelle en fait moi je l'aime
l'intervention était prévu depuis longue
date et il m'appelle pour me dire écoute
on change la date de l'intervention
parce qu'il y a Jean-Luc Delarue qui
commence sur le Tour de France et il
veut commencer par par le lycée à
Quimper voilà
et là alors vous appelez lui vous dit tu
me connais et vous vous lui répondez
avec tout ce qu'on dit sur toi il vaut
mieux qu'on fasse comme si je te
connaissais pas
avant de le connaître vous pensiez quoi
de lui
voilà j'entendais ce que tu m'entends
quoi donc effectivement
voilà l'animateur de la chambre idéal
voilà c'est toujours de ce qui pouvait
se passer une fois qu'il avait quitté
les plateaux de télévision aucune
j'étais même surpris
vous êtes rencontrés voilà Jean-Luc
Delarue vous dit j'ai 47 ans je suis
dépendant à la cocaïne j'ai arrêté il y
a 6 mois là il y a un blanc il ajoute
c'est dur c'est super dur
mais la cocaïne c'est si dur que ça
s'arrêtait
psychologique est très très et puis t'en
prendre
puis la descente elle est laborieuse
dès le début ça accroché entre vous
alors là vous décidez de faire le tour
de France ensemble en camping-car vous
dormiez tous les deux dans le
camping-car
avant
de lui
une personne avec lui c'est tout
alors la première réunion est assez
décevante parce que Jean-Luc parle pas
beaucoup il s'éclipse assez vite il sert
pas les mains des gens qui étaient là
ici une panne autographe alors vous vous
êtes non seulement déçu comme elle mais
aussi énervé vous lui dites Jean-Luc ce
qu'on a fait ce soir c'est de la merde
je suis fatigué
j'ai juste fait 600 km de plus que tout
mais ça s'apprend que 5 minutes ça prend
10 minutes et très vite
raison je te remercie de me parler
franchement grâce à toi j'atterris donc
il accepte dès le départ en rapport
parfaitement égalitaire
alors le plus dur en fait dites-vous
c'est de gérer les revival c'est à dire
des crises de manque qui qui reviennent
comme ça de temps en temps quoi pas du
tout d'une façon régulière et dans ces
cas-là vous dites il est blanc comme un
linge il est tremblant il est
dégoulinant enfin c'est vraiment très
très violent quoi
allonger 2 minutes
puis après ça
son grand frère d'une certaine façon
alors voilà peu à peu quand même il
reprend le dessus
après les conférences que vous faites
tous les deux dans les écoles dans les
collèges dans les lycées ils parlent
pendant des heures avec les gens sur le
parking vous dites pour la première fois
de sa vie en fait il pouvait être
sincère
on sentait qu'il y avait plus de
barrières il faisait du bien aux gens on
pensait franchement ce qui est très beau
dans votre histoire à tous les deux
c'est que vous faites découvrir
mutuellement des choses un peu comme
intouchable c'est à dire que par exemple
il vous amène dans un musée vous étiez
jamais dans un musée donc il y a une
espèce d'échange comme ça qui est tout à
fait touchant
alors quelle image vous gardez de lui
il me manque
après la tournée vous l'avez vu
régulièrement non c'est on s'est appelé
ça envoyer des messages vous dites c'est
le mec le plus fort que j'ai croisé dans
ma vie il a arrêté la cam en six mois
moi il m'a fallu 10 ans
ça c'est
ça ça restera
une belle histoire quand même
j'ai été touché très personnellement par
les sujets toxicomanie et quand je vois
aujourd'hui les débats qu'on a sur la
possibilité de légaliser de réaliser ne
serait-ce que ces salles de shoot moi ça
me ça me révolte parce que vous le dites
d'ailleurs très bien les conséquences
sont irréversibles je ne crois pas je
vais peut-être dire quelque chose qui va
peut-être en choquer certains on ne
guérit pas de la toxicomanie on ne
guérit pas de la drogue c'est pour ça
que moi je suis contre les salles de
shoot certains disent qu'on est sectaire
ou qu'on est conservateur c'est-à-dire
que chacun va arriver avec sa drogue
dans ses salles pour se droguer on ne
sait pas ce qu'ils prennent moi j'ai eu
mon frère quand il est passé
effectivement du cannabis c'est pas ce
qui prenait il est passé à l'héroïne et
puis à l'ammoniac il a la drogue était
coupée l'héroïne était coupée à
l'ammoniaque c'est ses copains sont
morts de Bordeaux on a eu moi j'ai
tellement vu de jeunes tomber il a eu un
peu plus de chance que les autres dans
la mesure où on payait des cures de
désintoxication mais comme vous dites il
passait son temps à dîner pour obtenir
sa drogue et nous on notre temps à payer
des cures de désintoxication donc on en
sort pas donc le meilleur moyen c'est de
faire ce que vous faites de la
prévention de la sensibilisation sur les
dangers de la drogue et puis qu'on ait
une vraie politique de prévention de la
toxicomanie mais surtout pas la
légaliser et surtout pas l'organiser en
fait c'est clair
ce qui est déjà en place en matière de
réduction des risques aujourd'hui moi
j'ai une hépatite C moi je me suis
contaminé à l'usage de la seringue si à
mon époque il y avait des salles de
shoot aujourd'hui j'aurais pas
l'hépatite C bien en tous les cas ce
qu'il faut dire effectivement à ceux qui
n'ont jamais pris ne commençait jamais
voilà franchement ça sert à rien et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu